what do you think this is strange
I was really compelled to be in this
video because I've been really wanting
to try the tub shroom I have a lot of
hair and I just moved in with my
roommate Janine who also has a lot of
hair do you know where Donnie oh yeah I
have a lot of hair though touch my hair
see how thick it is oh it's big yeah I
think it's gonna save me money on Drano
and I think it's gonna catch all my hair
and make my lane wide happy I don't know
if this thing can work but if it can
that would be amazing
here is the tub shroom it's really still
akane feels like a dogs chew toy or
something you should squish so since our
shower is a shower or not the tub we
have to take out the drain and put it in
stall this see how easy it is it does
look like a little bit like a tum shroom
it looks like there's a few hairs in
there not a lot I also pushed some to
the side it's been the third wash it
kind of got clogged so I'm gonna take it
out and for sure good it'll got its
little gross it's in a week let's see
how this looks I just took a shower as
you can see all these water spots whoa
alright gonna be a little bit more but
eh oh yes I don't want to be doing this
every single time I hate here look Scott
I hate this I hate it I handle it so
much this is just this week that's not
even a lot and it was like super super
stopped up it looks like it works I did
not expect this much hair goes through
to this drink here is my hair jar for
the week
yikes it's about like a fistful of hair
I also want to say that the tub shroom
is one of those cool gross products Wow
it's kind of satisfying to see all of
your gross hair like altogether
collected and you being able to throw it
out oh there's something very gratifying
about that stuff so if you're that type
of person
please definitely get the tub shroom I
got thrown away
[Music]
[Music]